so I've got quite strong views on this
which is that everybody wants to be a
bodybuilder but nobody wants to lift no
heavy ass weight have you ever spent
weeks trying to improve your hammock ooh
for example that's because because you
were took you a read an article on tea
nation that spoke about how it attacked
the biceps slightly differently and you
felt like that was what your life was
missing if you know whose is is if you
know whose is is yeah that's it like
that's the certificate like if you know
whose is is this will all completely
make sense to you and your job you start
that nodding along did the squats and
milk program which is so three times a
week
you take your ten rap marks you do a set
of ten and then you keep the bar on your
back and you take five to ten deep
breaths and you do another rap and you
keep doing that until you hit 20 and
then you have a gallon of milk a day so
I was having a gallon of whole milk four
point seven liters of whole milk every
day just sat in class and I remember
doing this and like throwing up
raspberry way down my top while I would
had the bar in my back doing these like
scores note being so out of breath
I'm joined by Johnny and Youssef from
propane fitness calm look hellos so good
to see you you did some boxing I was
just enjoying the effect it's quite that
today we are talking about the fitness
menopause it's something that we've
dropped on podcasts for the last couple
of years I'll start off I'll try and
give a broad definition so everyone
knows what we're talking about and them
all we'll take it from there
so fitness menopause was something that
I'd identified within myself toward my
late twenties when I'd been doing bro
lifts in fitness stuff bodybuilding for
a while and realized as I became
chronically aware of my own mortality as
I approached 30 realized that I was
getting out of breath going up a big
hill and I was kind of a little bit
bored of just doing you know chest
Monday's and chest Tuesday's and chest
Wednesday's and curls and stuff like
that and training purely for aesthetics
and I was just disenchanted I kind of
lost my love with training certainly
lost the motivation to do it without
really grinding myself to get out of bed
and go to the gym so then just started
trying to do different things the
fitness menopause describes a period I
think in a lot of Fitness people's lives
who perhaps have just entered into the
world of training by doing bodybuilding
or bro style lifting from just the age
of teens or early 20s or whatever and
then never tried anything else and as
they approached their late twenties they
think oh hang on like this this maybe
isn't fulfilling me in quite the way
that I thought how do you think about
that as a definition you reckon that's
about right that's about right it
applies to a very specific subsection of
people and Oh are we Millennials rawr we
know technically it's 84 84 till 96 okay
so I think in that case then Millennials
tend to fall into this bracket quite
well because there was this surge of the
popularity of weightlifting bodybuilding
that kind of stuff
kind of coinciding with like t nation's
rise and fall and then bodybuilding.com
and all of these like like simply
shredded remember that yeah so all of
those kind of things and so most 18 to
22 year old guys got swept up in this
and usually it was the only kind of
physical activity they dared apart from
maybe five aside which is the other like
most popular young male activity I've
heard so yeah I think most people will
have gone through a few years of that
and Johnny and I always say that the
minimum entry requirement to even
consider having been in the fitness
menopause or gone through it is you have
to have done three to five years of PEC
deck and life press that's that's just
how I think like anyone not like you
know when you feel like you're one of
these people who did something before
was cool so I think we all did fitness
before it was cool and now as loads of
people willing to do fitness because
it's a bit cool so like people are
getting into this destroying sports and
starting and you just think like you
just image the real real fitness we like
the induction you haven't had like the
like have you ever spent weeks trying to
improve your hammer curl for example
that's because because you were took you
a read an article on tee nation that
spoke about how it's like attacked the
biceps slightly differently and you felt
like that was what your life was missing
did you practice two kilogram Arnold
press just so that you could really get
the form down yeah so you totally right
here's my reasoning for why I think
people fall into bodybuilding timings
one of them so definitely if you're
anyone probably now in 2020 between the
age of 26 and 34 probably you'll have
been a seen this rise T nation
bodybuilding.com Muscle & Fitness stuff
like it's if you know if you know whose
is is if you know whose is is yeah
that's it that's the certificate like if
you know whose is is this will all
completely make sense to you and you'll
just be shocked they're nodding along if
you don't know whose is is this for like
one
I quite like Google yes so here's my
reasoning timings one of them but my
other reason and this is why I think the
front end of the bodybuilding and
fitness training that kind of fitness
training funnel continues to get good
traffic in the front end is that it's
the type of training with the lowest
mechanical barriers to entry and the
lowest amount of skill requirement of
any physical sport on the planet but I
can take anyone who's listening I can
take your mum into the gym tomorrow
teach her a supinated bicep curl to
probably within about 80% of the
compliance and proficiency that I can do
it in after 15 years of training yeah
and you can increase her back way to get
her a sick taper get a jack get your mum
jacked so that she looks real mean when
she's walking the dog
but yeah the the barriers to entry to
doing bodybuilding is so so low and
people don't like doing stuff that they
suck at you know like think about
weightlifting the snatch is essentially
an impossible movement that it's
completely really impossible and and
some people just do that and another one
all their life you know clock is still
not clock off just those variations of
snatch and clean and jerk and he's like
that he's in his forties and still
massive but you get my point like people
don't like doing stuff that's
challenging mechanically cuz they feel
silly whereas you can go into a gym
tomorrow and get externalized rewards
socialized rewards don't really need to
worry about what the what the
internalized games are it's like wow I
can't really touch my toes anymore and
maybe my shoulder aches a bit but look
at that I've gained an inch on my chest
well we've all been involved in hunt
like a big guy in the gym you're like 19
big guy on the gym who's been like
strutting around working up to a big set
of incline dumbbell press he comes oh he
goes like me who's turned off a doubles
first please and you have to pick up the
dumbbell and give it to him and then you
watch him go
[Music]
yeah because he feels good at it because
he can just set his own rules like no
one's checking his form on his incline
dumbbell press it's like well I lifted
the biggest dumbbells in the gym mate
that's like the the entry-level isn't it
the way you can you can even set your
own rules for range of motion and
everything else powerlifting is kind of
the next level up but it still is very
much unfortunately like the the sport
for non athletes yeah and it's why it's
got the reputation Oh like at least a
beginner and kind of low intermediate
level is that it it's just got the
reputation of like people who were never
any good at any other sport or athletic
activity and and just wildly after that
Nick is it well no and it allows people
to justify being being fat not being
able to touch their toes like all of the
kind of things that would normally just
not fly in another sport but instead it
is very much it's terribly during
training like the competition you see
people that clearly do not need like
intro work our intro competition Haribo
and burgers and stuff and then they go
go out from McDonald's at the end of the
having done nine reps that day the
competition so I'm gonna be I I'm gonna
defend powerlifting here I feel like
people will be expecting me to I
completely agree with us until you reach
like national level especially like
national in the US and then the
international level hundred percent but
when you bump into a Polish bloke who's
pulling like 410 with like neck
striations you're like what's happened
there is that you you're lucky yeah
that's not who is an athlete and as
you've put them in their sport well
often when you look at it like when you
look at their background it's like so
like Tom Martin you look at his
background you're like ah yeah hundred
meter sprinter
yeah of course but like people who like
fell out of it I think the people who
you tend to like get like like we're
doing rugby at a really high level
stop playing rugby and they're like oh
well I lift weights um I want to do that
and before they know it they're like po
deeming the national level they're
already figure out why the year is like
well where's the competition on this
thing it's it's a good point about the
low-end level on powerlifting but being
honest like watch a scheitz and the
league football team play you know
you're not exactly gonna be watching
[ __ ] Christian or an old I'll go at
it so you're right at the bottom end of
that but at least those football players
aren't just picking the ball up and
running with it and saying oh well made
this is actually a little
but for my PAC development so it doesn't
really matter so yeah I think that's why
the two main reasons are path of least
resistance that it's kind of quite well
known and easy to do and easily
accessible and you can get a membership
at some big corporate gym for like 15
pounds a month which it which is
phenomenal right like you know the
funding you can get 24-hour gym
memberships in a city for 15 quid a
month is just insane in some but they're
going in there to do you know what do
you think a typical bodybuilding program
consists of maybe 25 movements like 25
main movements yeah five days a week
yeah yeah something like that
yeah I mean yeah it's I just think that
like people who are starting the fitness
journey now it's just [ __ ] for them like
it was way back back when no one really
knew what the crack was and there was
going up yours without making any
progress but like in the back of your
mind like I remember spending 40 quid on
surge workout fuel from tee nation
pretty pretty confident that it was
[ __ ] but there's that thing in the
back of your mind of like yeah but what
if it is the type of carbohydrate in
there
right what if it is the fact that race
is easier it is leucine rich and this is
gonna be the thing for me this is gonna
be like where everyone's gonna make I
have [ __ ] fish in the progress
Johnny's made it because the surgery
workout feel remember thinking I always
got cyclic dextrins and maybe that's
exactly what and you look it up and it's
like it's the main component in Febreze
spray yeah and you like I remember
reading onyx liquor in our unthaw sidon
ingredient in there you go 3G when you
look at like some blueberry yogurt and
they've got anthocyanin and you're like
mmm okay me maybe it's not that when
like my uncle yogurt also has a bit of
it in like it's probably not that
special but then you look over and your
mum's eating some and just just got like
striations and I by 7 you're like [ __ ]
separation between the bicep and tricep
and I've none of that
for your muscle you better go clean your
room yeah so okay so that's that's why I
think people fall into kind of laissez
this path of least resistance and here's
the question that I want most people
that are listening to try and answer and
it is if you're doing a bodybuilding
program or if most of your training
career has been spent doing bodybuilding
typical bro style training as a guy or a
girl do you like bodybuilding or do you
like exercising because those are not
the same thing
yeah so I've got quite strong views on
this which is that everybody wants to be
a bodybuilder but nobody wants to lift
no heavy ass weight no my my thought is
that everyone has it's one of the the
ancient axioms isn't it of life written
in stone by Ron Coleman Ronald ah so the
reality is that everyone has
bodybuilding goals there is such a small
percentage of the world and that they're
they're like a weird kind of like fetish
group aren't they like feeders and that
kind of thing that don't want girls less
fat and more muscle so they fear they're
like no point not 1% of people that have
this weird fetish what have like an
inverse bodybuilding goal but okay I
mean let me rephrase let me rephrase the
way that I put it
do you like bodybuilding training or do
you like exercise so I think that
probably most people I think the number
of people who like exercise probably
don't like it because it's exercise
if you don't mean like they don't no one
liked bodybuilding necessarily no one
really likes even like the more modern
stuff like how many people get really
obsessed with certain aspects of
powerlifting certain aspects of CrossFit
they just like what they think it's
going to do for them or what they kind
of get out of it they get a little bit
of props on social media people share
their new lifts they hit a new front I'm
and I my experience has been throughout
Fitness like I desperately wanted ABS
because I was convinced that that was
gonna improve my life got it knows that
mmm and then I desperately wanted a 300
kilo deadlift because I was like well
that means I win if I go three tequila's
I'll have got it as a mmmm okay
and then like the goal just kind of
drift past and you know while I could
get lean again but doesn't really do
much for me like I could add 10 kilos my
deadlift but like that be a proper faff
that's maybe what fueled the fitness
menopause for you is that you have to
you have to hit all these big
achievements and then you like didn't
really yeah I think that people go
people attach onto a mode of exercise
because they they believe that the
outcome of it will be a huge deal for
them and it to be honest it is like I
think that probably what what I've
gained from Fitness's is a big deal but
you kind of hit these milestones and
then you think alright well I'm kind of
done with bodybuilding now like I've
I've done it I've taken a progress for
I'm really happy maybe I should start
doing something that's competitive maybe
I'll get into triathlons or I think I
think there's a good point to be made
there about the fact that you kind of do
need to pay your dues if you've got this
unticked box with regards to physical
development in some other area it is a
good idea to take that first it's that
navall rubber [ __ ] ism where he says it
is far easier to achieve your material
desires than to recount them and it's
like I would much sooner not what not be
bothered about being lean because I've
been lean they're not mothered about
being lean just because I gave up yeah
you'd always have that like sense the
back it's like you from single-digit
body fat yeah like Johnny definitely
takes that box hard in like you know you
went that you competed at Worlds and
then you know then realise that actually
like
placing at Worlds and winning worlds is
so much more effort compared to getting
there then like because the curve of
like return on investment
suddenly should the people that know
what is world's world champion it's just
the top it's just the moat that like the
highest level in IPF but like honestly
like which is what what's IPF uh so
there's the international pilot and
Federation which is often seen as being
like the like the best won't be in
because the rules are the most strict
they've got stringent drug testing and
all that sort of stuff I think they're
technically like the most strict on
depth and like what you can and can't do
in the bench press and all sort of stuff
earns the GBP F and there's the EPF
which is the European power in
Federation so if you place at nationals
you go to Europeans if you do alright
Europeans you can sometimes be selected
for worlds so that happens a Mills and
you've got GB Singler t-shirt that is
the whole thing to be honest I think
it's because Tom Martin couldn't do it
that year like seriously but you know at
least art at least I'm honest about that
I think I I get really riled up by
people who I'm gonna offend some people
here I get really rather like you've got
like people who are legit like really
strong been training a long time that
should be a world and then you've got
people who get to worlds because of a
sort of an administrative process that
where a box needed to be like a for
someone need to fill a form in so you've
gone the world and like I just don't
think that the same thing personally but
anyway so if I hear you I can hear
you're tiptoeing around the issue that
you're trying to get to so the reason is
the reason is I watched Tony cliff in
the Gbps Facebook group say something
like a carbon were exactly what he did
but something like everyone's like
everyone's a paper champion these days
or everyone's got like a everyone's got
a medal and everyone's been they
Europeans because of like they competed
where there's only two people in the
weight class and he really really liked
people got really offended and I can see
why they got a funding because he's like
discrediting a lot of people but the
reason why I don't really like to say
our in the world's because I honestly
don't really feel like I deserve to be
there because I think I went there
because Tom market like if Tom Martin
had gone he'd have probably meddled
whereas I didn't well so like you have
the singlet from that year and not Tom
Martin I say however you I don't think
Tom Martin actually has that singular at
all black considered getting it framed
or is it framed yeah you told me no I
have it like so I have my European one
and then I have when SBT we realize like
should really put some money into this
and it stopped just being like a Union
Jack like I end on to a singlet and it
started being like a full you couldn't
buy um it's just in my drawer dude you
should do it so I told you this story
Sony Webster had his from I think the
Commonwealth and we live from the
Olympics so fair enough
framed with that with like a special
bracketed light down lighting it and
like [ __ ] it man I think you know I
think if I had been the Olympics I do
that too I don't see it is the silliest
you've you have made it to the peak of
the sport that you chose to put most of
your Fitness career into I think yeah
okay well thank you I I see why you
think that aside just about Tom Martin
just because he and we explain who he is
briefly yes it's not same about 20 he's
a guy who he went a bit viral like a
good few years ago now probably six
seven years ago because 83 kilos he died
left at 3:40 and everyone was yeah 340
kilograms
yeah so the heaviest thing you've ever
moved in your life ever probably like a
single object that isn't like a car
you've ever seen in your life
heavier than that think like small cow
and so and and he didn't look like a
lifter he was he was like came straight
up sprinting and just happened to have a
freak deadlift like obviously a lot of
training as well and then people were
commenting being like this isn't real
look he's on drugs or whatever and and
then he started to go up away class
competed against Johnny there's a great
video on Instagram of him on the podium
doing a like a juddery deadlift and then
puts it down and the camera just pans to
Johnny and he's just going
cuz I just come off so I just come off
the platform after having trying to pull
300 kilos and farted at Nationals so
like the finish buddy
it didn't even push because he like well
then yeah I think use of headaches you
starting behind but no one else heard
and go on why did I mean what happened
there did that mean that you lost your
bracing tense you know what yeah a
little bit of fart can you put it you
put a belt on you create trying to
create all this like intra-abdominal
pressure
how much fart was missing just enough to
just just hey the edge off and here you
don't want to mythic to do a Mac so
bless it called turtle head like you
don't want that very Logan you don't
need to be parroting yeah so I just
missed 300 and then Tom comes and I was
his go his turn and so this guy like he
he's kind of sprinting menopause
probably probably at the top of his game
regionally with that found that he had a
a what do they call that penchant
partial food for deadlifting went up a
weight class hit very good levels in me
in the IPF got sick of all of the the
bollocks
around that got loads of drug
accusations left the IPF went up like
two more week classes and just got
absolutely huge and increased his
deadlift by like a hundred kilos and
competing in a non tested Federation
yeah he's never come out and said like
I've started taking drugs now but it's
quite clear when you leave a tested
Federation and go and could be in a non
tacit Federation and all your left's go
up
it's very hugely as well it since he's
squatting I think over 400 now police
pulled 420 feet most impressive things
he's I've ever seen him do one was at
that competition where he comes out no
hype at all not he's barely even a
facial expressions missus like a 270
squat in the bottom so it goes all the
way down tries to drive up can't even
clergy like a hard-line some good try
third attempt comes out exactly the same
weight and smokes it so there's not a
lot of caffeine leaves and there's a
video on Instagram
passing out mid squat and like mid mid
rep and still nearly locks it out like
that that's why when people say when you
said powerlifting so full of people who
are very athletic
like there's a video of Tom cleaning 180
like it's nothing oh yeah yeah what what
I'm saying it's like at the beginner an
intermediate level like the the barriers
to entry are very low and then as you
approach the top if the curve flattens
so quickly and to then go from even note
like world's level as you said to go
from attending worlds to placing at
worlds it comes like the five units or
visible tasks yeah yeah okay okay so
that's that's I think a nice little bit
of framing so I think again for the
people that are listening my main
question is do you enjoy a bodybuilding
style of training do you enjoy chests on
a Monday and legs on a Tuesday and
shoulders on a wedding stone blah blah
blah five sets of [ __ ] ten to
fourteen or whatever it might be and
I'll dimmi warm-ups and I'll do my
external rotations and all that sevens
like it's not what you enjoy or do enjoy
exercise because especially for a lot of
guys that are listening but some girls
as well you'll have done a bunch of
sports at school probably after-school
Club something like that maybe you
played football or rugby or cricket or
you know America baseball American
football whatever it might be and then
you get to college or uni and realize
that there's distractions of drinking
and partying and getting in
relationships and stuff like that and
then you think well I need something
which is flexible in terms of time
doesn't have very many barriers to entry
and bolsters my confidence in a very
socialized way rather than in an
achievement sized way and I just think
what it leads a lot of people to do is
get to their mid to late 20s and think
[ __ ] hell I haven't really actually
indulged my desires in terms of a
physical output for a very very long
time the type the domain that I've been
operating within hasn't actually made me
feel that much better at all I've looked
Jack to do whatever but
I'm gonna try I wonder what yoga is like
I wonder what fight in Zico I wonder
what Brazilian jiu-jitsu is like I
wonder what CrossFit's like and then
inevitably what you see when people
pivot and make that transition is that
because it's firstly because there's
novelty effect but secondly because they
perhaps genuinely have found something
that they enjoy as a sport or as an
athletic pursuit the compliance goes up
and when the compliance goes up the
training volume goes up and when the
training volume goes up their condition
and their progress increases so you
actually realize that perhaps stopping
to doing a bodybuilding program which
you low-key hate might be one of the
best things you could do for your
bodybuilding goals by switching to
something else now there's a couple of
caveats if you want to keep on making
growth and gains you need to make sure
that whatever you're choosing to do has
some form of loading it also needs to
have some form of progressive overload
in there also needs to have some form of
intensity you know like no one's getting
jacked doing yoga unless it's a very
specific type of yoga which is like a
lot of power yoga with you know yin yoga
isn't getting anyone jacked but yeah my
point is I just think a lot more people
than you realize it would be
significantly happier doing a different
type of sport mmm-hmm
I think it carries on been through the
energy phase yeah like why do they need
to do that why do they need to go
through the unit everyone has to gain a
basic level of muscle mass and strength
and this cert like 99% of people who are
SI who are untrained like most of their
problems could be fixed by just getting
a bodyweight squat and a body way but
you know like just hitting basic targets
with even like rehab injury type stuff
yeah you know when you see we've talked
about this on other podcasts I think
when you see girls wearing ugg boots and
they're like they've got like valgus
knee and their hips just uh and they
just look really like floppy and and and
they're always complaining of hip issues
and and you like if you just could squat
60 kilos so much of your life would be
sorted out yeah clamshells twice a week
[Music]
those things with the bands and yeah I
think it's like it's just it's just
general gaining general body awareness
and what it feels like to to push
yourself physically I think it's really
easy to gain experience with that with
like a barbell or machine based
resistance training so something that I
saw when I did CrossFit fir on like six
months was there's people in there who
clearly like found CrossFit off the
light like Eucharist like found it off
the back of having spent a lot of time
doing a bodybuilding based training and
a lot of it like someone gives you a
dumbbell no problem yeah
seen a dumbbell before done a lot of
[ __ ] with a dumbbell dumbbells fine like
that the more sort of and kind of the
the base layer like of Maslow's
hierarchy and CrossFit is is sorted like
they can give you a barbell I can give
you can say Chris jump onto that and
you're fine but if you I just just love
like your concept of being given a
dunbar me like I'm familiar with one of
these well that's that's just how I felt
about like if if it was a CrossFit
workout where like Tim stands up and
goes barbell here dumbbell there and I'm
like I don't do those got it but if it's
like run but yeah so like I think when
people you also seen the person who's
like it's a first CrossFit session and
never maybe never trained before and the
idea of doing like a push press if I
said to either of you do a push press
right yeah fine I'm a I've done push
press that you have stunned the AI
bodybuilders shoulders back so Katya
right we've all done a push press yeah
so I put you put that and we've also all
like taking asset to failure don't like
pushed ourselves physically beyond where
we thought and I think you do have to
push pressed 110 that's my baby someone
gives you a barbell with 110 on and
you're like I firstly I kind of know
what I'm capable of here
secondly I know what it feels like to
miss thirdly I know sort of I have a few
technique use in my mind give someone
who's never touched over what barbell
before and say push press that I like
push press what's a barbell how can I do
with a mixed grip yeah you know yeah
this is something about watching someone
who's moved up but a lot of our bells
around there's a certain kind of grace
yeah like that you never see this
do you not I mean I think honestly man I
think a big part of that just comes from
doing athletics as a kid but again with
that like if there's people listening
who did some for you know especially
with girls
[ __ ] tons of girls at my school were
doing like dance or other kind of like
dance associated outputs and you think
like your your proprioception your
ability to understand where your body is
in space and how to move it from A to B
is so much more advanced than a [ __ ]
donkey kick back like why why are you
doing like three kilo tricep extensions
like this with a real regression is yeah
when I've got tons and tons of
biomechanical biomechanical control just
sat latent in your brain so it's not I
wonder if that's just people like
compartmentalizing they're there cuz
yeah like to have a background in dance
like the amount of proprioception you
need like I'm yeah I I've done
gymnastics for years and I still look at
the dancers and think bloody hell that's
a whole nother level so yeah like if you
can cross over those skills and I like
I'm so grateful that I had a background
in gymnastics because I see so many
people at my age or even five ten years
younger though I wish I did a bit more
of that stuff when I was younger and
it's really hard now and they feel
really creaky and to have just had some
lower level gymnastics skill when you're
younger just means that yeah like you
pick up any new skills so easily accept
anything with a ball I'm terrible at you
are basically everything with the ball
but I mean with the frisbee ah just bad
with the frisbee a throw yeah that's
again that's another that's another
really good point no like think about
what your athletic bases especially you
go back to guys a lot guys might have
done that you say football or rugby or
something as a kid that you have a
really solid aerobic base really solid
you'll understand how to run you'll
understand how to
cut and change direction and like you
know even just going from that to just
doing 5ks
is probably not maximizing what you're
what you're capable of doing you know
obstacle racing or something like that
would actually be maximizing your
Fitness inheritance I suppose a little
bit better
mmm I think yeah I don't know I say I
just think why don't you worm
why don't you both give us a 30,000 foot
view of your fitness careers and how the
how the menopause here I think that
would be interesting
okay go for it honey
fifteen sixteen fat kid start getting
bullied I was like right well I'm not
having that so started started watched a
rocky film started running realized
running wasn't the answer right a couple
of copies to men's health men's fitness
start doing loads of kills like loads of
curls and I press up some ice or stuff
then gyms or progressively worked his
way through like that's when I met you
saw for the first time when he was doing
like squats three times a week in
drinking a gallon milk a day I think
just yeah lots of that stuff I like lots
of like lots of I remember like the
first time trying creating and all sort
of stuff just in this desperate attempt
to get lean for the first time got lean
for the first time then realized
actually like being strong and training
so then like did my first bulk ever and
realized that gaining what gaining
weight and gaining strength was actually
more exciting than losing weight and
losing strength I stirred like 13 13
blocks of 531 hit my first ever like
fire and a pound deadlift it's quite 200
kilos the first time with Youssef in
where were we
Shanta it was a not no tenten tenten
tenten gym and then like my visit with
security cameras and cages around the
security cameras first quite tunic ears
in the corner in that gym and that kind
of became an addiction so I got into dem
affairs parla fin competition because
you so suggested I did and it would
literally went like first competition
first
squat I ever did set a regional record
second squad I did broke my own regional
record won that competition
went to Nationals came third when the
Europeans when the world
there's something to this yes like there
was like my first six powerlifting
competition so I said this is quite fun
this like I get like the GB kit and all
this is meant but then my years a year
25:10 of the year 20 year be 2015 Oh in
the worlds for 25 yep and then kind of
after that trying to juggle it around
like propane taking off and and like
doing more work in the business and
you've kind of scratched at it so it
starts become less and less interesting
and probably go back a year was when
that came to a head and I was just like
man like I just cannot motivate myself
to so I moved up a weight class as well
so for the first time in my life about
two years ago stopped being lean all the
time and I was like I'd gained quite a
lot of weight and I was dealing with
this other like tactically so what you'd
tactically gained weight yeah yeah yeah
well yeah I didn't like myself it wasn't
like you'd gone to seed or something
it's that you decided no I wanted to
move up a weight class
so I'd had four or five consecutive
competitions in the 93 s where my total
hadn't moved and I was having to like
aggressively wake up for the
competitions and a loss or stuff so
moved up a weight class hit bigger
numbers so hit like a 250 squat 312
deadlift 160 bench ripped my adductor in
the bottom of a squat and when that
happened I was like [ __ ] me man like all
this work got a video of that way yeah
of my adductor actually yeah awful I
then had to chase Dexter he was a puppy
at the time round around about with a
torn hamstring an hour later which I'm
convinced was like the that was it was
just reminding you I still remember
though I remember limping out the house
the axe is slipping out his harness and
then just like bang and you like before
you know you had got them in your arms
you know
I just ripped my eye doctor manette go
but it was fine there yeah weird but
yeah so that led to I remember sat
watching across her documentary like the
latest one that just came out at the
time don't know what it would be
redeemed in the diamond maybe you're
raising it road to the fittest yeah yeah
and I was like man like because you were
at the time where you'd been doing
Crossfit for maybe two years or
something at that point so I did what's
the cross for workouts like 10 9 8 7 6 5
4 3 2 1 squat bench deadlift bench
cleaning joke yeah it was at Regionals
that year I can't remember buy another
one it was like Cindy or no Margaret
well Joanne did that and how that man
had wood like that was actually really
good fun then did six months of CrossFit
then I injured myself again twice in the
open so I was doing 21:59 2159 with the
deadlifts and handsome walks and I just
approached one fourth he like just 140
how bad can this be you get like seven
reps him you know yeah quite bad quite
quite bad yeah and I think I like dingy
Mahama a little bit did my wrist didn't
clean and jerk and now I'm cut like
honestly at the moment I'm kind of just
Fitness is just like totally
deprioritized for me should have a shame
but it does feel like what where I am at
now is the thing that I'm aggressively
chasing so if I go back to like nineteen
year old me I was aggressively chasing
Fitness I was aggressively chasing being
leaner getting stronger because of what
I thought I'd get from it and now I
think probably the same thing for me is
business I like put and other areas of
personal development all sort of stuff
just because I think I know that if I
put more effort into my fitness what I'd
go out of it's probably not what
maybe once expected so that's kind of my
journey no I think it's cool Seth what
do you give is yours
so yeah met I think met Johnny in like
the school gym at age of 16 I was doing
all sorts of stupid stuff like all the
like Pavel sat Celine and economy
remember the name of the guy who was
making you be like a thousand Hindu
squats and Hindu press ups every day it
was called like a comeback or
conditioning or something like that I've
got an image of Johnny trying a
pre-workout for the first time like it
became is like a free sample in like a
magazine yeah and then how'd you look
Matt yeah have you like two cables
behind him so holding on to the cables
and doing like a loaded sprint and then
stepping back and doing that again then
I discovered the strong left 5x5 did you
do sorry to interrupt didn't you do like
an arm program that was like arms mx5
thousands all kinds of sure there's it
because your original eight
transformation article you were talking
about doing like really high volume arm
work oh yeah I've basically done every
like free ebook and like ridiculous
programs and not surprisingly none of it
worked one because I ate like an
absolute pigeon then I bought some way
and I had like one scoop of it or like
almost a scoop of it once once every day
that I was training and I was thinking
my hobby it like despite eating maybe
800 calories a day started the strongly
5x5 program which that's when progress
started to move up just cuz I was using
a barbell doing some kind of progressive
overload did the squats and milk program
which is where you take so three times a
week
you take your ten rep marks with a squat
which there was no squat rack so I had
to just set up the bar on to like Jimmy
Olsen's wasn't a school haul yeah school
gymnastics it's like get underneath it
like squeeze underneath and let's start
my set you do a set of 10 which is your
10 rep marks and then you keep the bar
on your back and you take five to ten
deep breaths and you do another rep and
then you keep doing that until you hit
20 and then you have a gallon of milk a
day so I was having a gallon of whole
milk
4.7 liters of whole milk everyday just
sat in class and I remember doing this
and like throwing up
raspberry way down my top while I had
the bar in my back doing these like
squats about being so out of breath and
just like and like this was in a this
was in like a gym way again no squat
rack you just have to like fashion
together a bunch of kit so I must have
just looked a bit mental then went to
uni got got a coach based on Johnny's
don't know in fact this was sorry before
this so I was 59 kilos stayed around
that weight went a unique gained 31
kilos over three months so that is half
my body weight by basically drinking a
pint of cream kind of double cream every
night before bed glasses of olive oil
between meals cheesecake in the blender
just like real qualified real quality
weight my lifts didn't come up I told
you in our period yeah it's all muscle
because I'm a t-shirts were fitting
tighter so did that had mutant mass as
well like a weight gainer that's like
2,000 calories per serving
lots of vomiting throughout this period
just from like not from like purging but
just from like being so full
mechanically that if you make any sudden
movements if you carrying a really full
pint across a busy bar and someone
knocks into you right it goes it goes
all over the floor yeah look and so
after that got lean later on start to
gain more weight again AB D right away
just because mrs. when we were setting
up propane we were like oh we need a
needed transformation and then I was
like oh I'll give it a go I'm probably
like two weeks off being lean 90 kilos
it's like 90 kilos sitting in the
kitchen of my uni accommodation with the
two of us and Dan and we're like yeah
we'll start a fitness website and then
we all looked at each other like one of
us is going to have to get in shape for
this and you're like other I think in
the army rapid fat loss program Oh II
think peppers and doing like
high-intensity interval training and it
was sorry she was very modified fast
yeah like 700 calories a day of just
protein and yeah I think I was just so
deeply experimental and just wanting to
just try anything for her giggles later
on start did a powerlifting competition
Johnny and I started going to different
competitions then hired a coach on
Johnny's recommendation it was Eric
Helms we've had him on the podcast
multiple times now got very lean like
silly lean by this point like could see
pancreas secreting insulin like would
walk past the window and just see like
like striations and fasciculations in
like topically chest and stuff and like
you know when you start to see like in
image or as well had that got pretty
unwell with how lean I was like just
always run down like super food anxious
super like just dysfunctional acceptable
or being ill erectile dysfunction all
the stuff that was all of that yeah
really wired all the time as well didn't
Olympic lifting competition did multiple
powerlifting come to it like smash the
powerlifting competitions in that weight
class because I was just I just wasn't a
74 kilo lifter I was a 83 kilo enough to
hiding in in the weight class below
because I've managed like eliminate all
the body fat you got you got a drug test
it because you just had such tight delt
separation when it's like everyone else
comes off the platform like the outer
shape and then there's Youssef when he
like as soon as he tensions to pull the
bar off the ground there's like like
Chester's like thousands full [ __ ]
[Music]
it's quite funny in that situation
because in clothes you don't look like
you lift out of clothes people are like
no way you said before he loads yeah
it's a big dichotomy right mm-hm
yeah so then did we continuing to doing
gymnastics like throughout that and that
was kind of what initially got me into
weightlifting in the first place like
two conditions for gymnastics then had
an ongoing disc issue which I remember
Chris came to my house and brought like
a gift package which was like an
innocent smoothie I be soaring like a
bunch of drawers roll like that that was
lovely
because I was I remembered that the pain
was so bad you know I couldn't walk
really tearing up because you're moving
it was hurting so much once yeah like
just like spent a few days just lying on
the floor and like if you have to go to
the bathroom you're like oh no if I'm
like such a journey because you take
like an hour to like support yourself
over that coronated in getting ill in
hospital with an infections but then
kind of I think a disc itis or a just
worsening apart the gitis lost function
of my left leg for a bit for so for
about six months lost sensory motor
function of the the s1 dermatome at my
left leg me to me it was like sort of
like shuffling around for a few months
like I couldn't couldn't extend my left
foot thinking like well that's it I
finally done it like I've ignored all
the pain signals that lifting you know I
said well it's actually be totally
because of this this like bravado
attitude you see online of life if you
don't squat every day to a max you're a
[ __ ] and if you're in pain is it you
know you're just kind of train through
it and all this stuff and I just like
there was literally I've got a
screenshot of like some marketing thing
from tea nation of a guy saying I was
taking this micro PA supplement and I
gained 15 pounds of muscle even while I
was so ill that I had to drag an oxygen
canister around the gym with me and make
you like if that's not a responsible
marketing then remember the video that
was like Sebastian Cosette gained 400
pounds on his leg press and dropped 25%
body fat
yeah yes it did that program
bodybuilding well I I bodybuild a
bodybuilder
that was the galloped out of a blackops
body building projects you remember
really well produced you couldn't get
away with that now in the in the era of
gdpr there's no way yeah gdpr and covet
and complaints and like 30 modernism at
the time kids today will never know when
you could watch a video like that and
actually be legit convinced that like
this is all you need it was the i
bodybuilder program like how nice life
was when when the jack jack 3d
pre-workout had legal compounds in it
but literally had an unhappy mean i yeah
13.4 Emmaline
i believe it wasn't the derivative of
i'm feta mean or something yeah do you
remember the first time he took that
yeah what happened
very itchy face I also was because I was
taking a lot of know explain Oh explode
at the time that was mine anyway explode
was my it was my boy because I just
thought that the more nitric oxide that
I had in my body the the bigger I was so
I was just taking that and I'm like a
[ __ ] artist [ __ ] me [ __ ] off so I
would serve it in and it was actually
like the taste is not too bad it's like
lemon and lime sort of lovely flavor you
know it's pretty pretty easy to get down
definitely over measured it and I
remember spending most of that training
session just desperately scratching my
face like you get the blood capillaries
dilate right is that correct it's gone
is that why you I mean like all of the
effects of an unfair to mean like
there's always people talking about pill
Willie from from Jack Jack Jack 3d I
think I got a I got a seven rep PB so I
hit my three rep max for squats
for ten and then I was really unwell for
a week after this like I kind of
stumbled over Jim you know when you
start to see that the tunnel vision
start to kick in Moses in your
peripheral and then I was like oh and I
just went to bed
just ill for a few days for a long time
I remember looking at the because I
think I'd gone by this point I'd been
taking I mean we'd been trying like I
know exploding all these different
pretty workouts and I'd even gone like
off piste because this is back when in
the good old days when my protein the
way they worked was you could just buy
bags of individual supplements and sort
of like your everything yeah it my like
protein yeah exactly yeah like bike
before they were releasing like my vegan
bars you know when it was done properly
so I was I was already like mixing like
arginine and caffeine and like steering
all up in my neck Nicole Jim so when we
were looking at the exact like tribulus
all the stuff you could possibly get in
your pre-workout looked at the tub I'm
sure it said like no more than three
scoops as Oh bollocks
oh yeah I have a lot of coffee I have a
lot of stuff I'll just I'll try four
there's no way it's more caffeine than a
normal pre-workout it hit a I think I
got like usual it's just TV 34 six
deadlift which at the time was mental
like way over similar to user then went
to the cinema it was also my high carb
day went the cinema had two bags of wine
gums and then just got debilitating
Crump in the cinema so I remember like I
remember standing outside to meet the
st. man standing outside their showing
with my leg on a bin trying to stretch
up in like seething a really bad fame
and everyone's walking past Karen hi I'm
just like is something that I can see
that's a universal across both of yours
which is the part of the inflection
point where you changed your training
methodology occurred due to injuries of
one kind or another
yeah in a disenchantment with training a
lack of novelty in the training that you
were doing because you'd done a lot of
it already and then yeah I think
realizing that like all that
in doing was aggravating the injury and
just continuing to ignore the fact that
it was just making it worse and being
like why am I just pursuing loading my
body with more and more weight with no
particular end point because you can get
away with it when you're 18 and you just
basically made of like you're smoking
those packs of jelly jelly that you drop
in water just incredible I remember
being able to do like heavy like snatch
and then deadlift too remarks and then
go to gymnastics that evening and then
wake up the next day feeling absolutely
fine like just normal
no Dom's or anything now like I'd feel
like I've been hit by a bus remember
what I said to you my definition this is
this is why the fitness menopause is
such a robust concept because it is as
you become chronically aware of your own
mortality maybe you can get injured once
or twice maybe you're bounced back from
the injury doesn't quite happen as
quickly maybe you realize that your
fitness like actual genuine
cardiovascular fitness hasn't been cared
for apart from only in service of a cut
for like a long time like the only time
you ever get your heart rate up is in
the months of May June and bit of July
before the lads holiday or like the
girls the girls trip away and stuff and
yeah I think there's and the same for me
right the all of the different
categories that you guys identified
there from training to just have
externalized socialized rewards to then
getting a little bit bored with it so
then getting a little bit injured to
them trying a few things to them finding
something I'm happy with and then
dialing my training back and they're
actually finding a sense of fulfillment
and pleasure where training becomes
integrated into my life as opposed to
being my life which it was for quite a
long time man I think that it's actually
part of a broader menopause which occurs
but if I need to if saying menopause so
much is triggering I don't know whether
menopause is like a word that we really
shouldn't be using but it's the one that
we've chosen we are gonna be in a bit
troubled people know I think people know
what we mean good don't they good to
thank you voice of reason there yeah I
think it's part of a broader menopause
that you go through again
you know especially I think particularly
for guys because we mature so much so
much more slowly like there's so much
latent maturity that should have
occurred in men under the age of 25 and
then it kind of like it's you know when
you pull a spring and it's starting to
load up and load up and load up and then
the thing holding the spring at the back
let's go and it goes hmm well except for
the fact that you can I think you can
make a fart joke to a man of any age
it's still funny yeah you've got latent
like old school grandfathered in Joker's
like that haven't you yeah but yet I
think it's a part of that as well
because it was at the same time that I
made that switch to CrossFit that was
I'm gonna play around with a little bit
more self development and are maybe I'm
gonna question whether I should
deprogram the way that I use alcohol and
I maybe I should see if I can start
working on my sleep routine now maybe I
should do this podcast and start reading
and do you know a bunch of other things
so I think it all is part of a wider
change that people go through in their
lives but I genuinely believe that by
looking at different ways to integrate
Fitness into your life you can
potentially service some of those other
changes you know if you start to now
train for something which is genuinely
internally enjoyable to you which has
objective measures of performance which
I think's a really big thing like if all
that you're doing is subjective measures
of progress ie aesthetics and body
building you're never ever going to
actually know if you're making progress
and that's one of the reasons that I
think people have anxiety about the
training that they never actually know
if they're better you know it's like I'm
out and I actually like it I mean demap
delts look my delts look a bit better
than last year but like maybe my glutes
are a bit more down and blah blah like
so it it's one of the most depressing
things about bodybuilding as a sport
they're like even if you're a
professional bodybuilder yeah you can go
by measurements but really like the way
that it's ultimately judged is by a
subjective panel of judges preference
and there are mr. Olympius that have
been busting themselves for ages to try
it and they'll just never
win because the judges don't happen to
like the physique and you're hanging I
prefer a physique that's got a little
bit more traps like what the [ __ ] does
that what do you mean by that
where is again if you've got CrossFit
this is one of the it's definitely one
of the things that you can say about
CrossFit powerlifting weightlifting 100
kilos is 100 kilos but it's always going
to be a hundred kilos and if you lift it
10 times last week and then 11 times
this week you have made definitively by
definition you have made progress yeah
yeah the thing the thing that is good
about so the thing that's a challenge
about most strength sports most barbell
based sports probably not including
strongman is you are trying to improve
such a narrow range of things that it's
quite easy to have like especially once
you've been training for 3-4 years it's
quite easy to have like six months years
where you made it maybe don't make any
progress at all like I think my bench
stalls like for years like add up the
reps done take even nothing like
reactively nothing and you think well
what's the point where something like
CrossFit because the it's just this
broad plane of things you could improve
on it's a I think mentally it's easier
what all this it's why you start
slacklining Chris isn't it yeah
definitely I mean that's a perfect
example of something that is for no gain
other than I think it's quite fun and so
if you got you got to do it with me and
it's hard it's real challenging but I'm
not doing it because I think it's gonna
improve my glute gains I'm not gonna lie
and say that it is there's not a little
bit of me that wants to be good at it so
that I can show off I'm aware I'm aware
that that's probably in there that's why
we do anything yeah well III genuinely
like that
slacklining but for people that don't
know slackline it's kind of like less
weird
what's that thing used to do in the
circus
tightrope tightrope it's like less
weighted tightrope isn't it but you
could eat a flat piece of material you
can stand on and walk along and kind of
the real good people can go like this
but a bit a bit of bitte bitte bitte
bitte yeah wiggle from side to side um
but that with a podcast on in the
sunshine for an hour is for me what that
beautiful way to spend an afternoon
especially if it's a rest day from more
heavy heavily loaded training if you
told 21-year old Chris that my idea of a
good Sunday afternoon would be to go and
listen to a couple of fellas talk in a
room in a pair of wireless headphones
and stand on a flat piece of material in
between two trees in the park next to my
house I'd have been very very
disappointed by sure I guess I shows how
our preference is and I think most
people get into it to begin with because
they just want to be more attractive and
like more impressed either one impress
their mates or impress the bodybuilding
give me nobs yeah or like to fitness in
general at most people is because they
want to improve how they look and the
one who prefer the look to be more
impressive but I think once you've liked
that we've all entered the phase at
which like it actually stops being
impressive and starts being a bit weird
so like what we watch do you lift me 300
well yeah how much work how much you've
had to sacrifice to get there when you
see someone that is that lean you know
that they can't have that much else
going on in their life so this is the
bizarre thing about what signaling does
signaling in any form tells you a lot
more than just that one signal is okay
what are the 2nd 3rd 4th order effects
back upstream from whatever I'm seeing
in front of me like this particular
person who's unbelievably lean strong
big whatever it might be they have to
have some deficiencies else well they
have to have some side effects sure so
not necessarily deficiencies because
there's been some sacrifices that have
had to be made for that and yeah as your
preferences change across time I think
it's a no the other thing as well is
Jim Rose especially
they select or they identify a very
particular type of caricaturist ik a
caricature the girls don't actually find
all that attractive like if you gave a
lad that was just a normal fella who was
confident because he'd worked on being
socially capable and a guy who was much
more reserved didn't have any of the
social capabilities but did 531 for a
couple of years the guy that is able to
laugh and joke and go on with people in
a group he's going to be significantly
more popular socially and also
significantly better with the opposite
sex and the same I think goes for girls
as well but yeah that's a good point
like in terms of attractiveness like
from selecting for the things that
you're training for but even within that
as well so we've just posted an
Instagram post of
the attributes that people typically
train for intercept so that men
typically train for when they're when
they're wanting to look better is biceps
ABS shoulders triceps like whereas the
attributes that women on average prefer
physically in men are glutes back and
legs
so someone yeah I'll try and find the
citation but it's it basically says that
like we we are optimizing for the wrong
thing if you're if you're training to to
look better for the opposite sex like
the things that you think are important
are not the things that the you'll find
attractive in you assert I was saying
this to back at the other day we're just
walking deck joints to have this
realization of like you can tell a lot
about someone by how much they barbell
row yeah like you meet someone with a
huge barbell row and like that person
very patient wasn't an accident was
definitely wasn't an accident
what isn't doing really for any kind of
accrual because like who brags about the
barbell row you can't see the effects of
a barbell row in the mirror it is pure
just like I am in the pursuit of
self-improvement here and that's all I'm
after
I just want to slightly improve my
barbell row over time
I I don't think they were very dense
more attract well exactly yeah I just
don't think there are very many other
exercises you can say that off maybe a
dumbbell so any rowing movement chin up
probably as well but even that's a bit
appeals you didn't we bicep II yeah a
bit more showing deadlifts
don't know I think like that's the most
way you can move isn't it on an exercise
pretty much some people are doing right
like three-inch rack poles you like come
on meat yeah what's going on here stop
this you know look at that so yeah I
think that's a part of a broader change
that people have where they start to
remember that they used to do art as a
kid maybe I'm going to go and take an
art class or maybe I'm gonna start doing
another language or I'll reap lick up
the guitar and played that in however
many years or you know and this is to
some of the listeners who are older than
we are this might just sound like we're
going yes mate that's what getting
[ __ ] older is whereas to us we're
like a whole look at my money my body's
changing and my injuries aren't going
away as quickly and it's not worried you
[ __ ] I would quite like if
there's anyone listening who is over the
age of 35 40 and thinks that we're just
spouting absolute obvious truisms then
please comment and let us know
but everything's everything's obvious to
someone isn't it yeah like if we were if
we were genuinely putting out like
groundbreaking information here then I
think that's quite so I think Fitness
menopause is fairly groundbreaking I
think when you I think when you start to
map and man I hope that we've read
pilled the [ __ ] out of some people today
I hope that there's some listeners it
will go away and think I'm actually
gonna try a different form of training
because I don't feel that engaged with
my bro style split anymore I don't
really feel like it's benefiting me
across the board I'm sick of having my
progress judged purely subjectively
by myself like it not yeah people there
is something a bit like that so that's
very important for people that are at
the the full side of the curve at the
end of the serve there are also people
who are pre this curve and should not
assume that they've hit the fitness
menopause if you've been training less
than two three years you are nowhere
near the fitness menopause and if
anything if you don't lift weights and
you and you're doing other stuff you
will always benefit from getting you'll
still get a lot of the the like the
low-hanging fruit from lifting weights
just for a bit
it's just you know basic level
competence and then you can do whatever
you you but if you like its I mean
that's coming from a proper proper
doctor I mean not from a doctor not your
doctor we are not we are not a doctor
but he is a doctor and yeah what was it
that you said before the a lot of the
biomechanical problems and health
problems that you get would be fixed if
someone can do a bodyweight squat and a
push-up Oh in terms of soft-tissue
niggling injuries and like all that kind
of stuff
absolutely but there is also just a pure
mortality improvement like all cause
mortality
it went one of the biggest factors is
grip strength and yes that's correlation
and it might be the people who are dying
have weaker grip and so on but if you
improve your grip strength through the
improve your total muscle mass there are
so many metabolic cardiovascular and
just overall mortality improvements and
reduction in risk that you can get from
that Plus you look better you feel
better like it's a no brainer to lift
weights for a bit and just get basic
levels of strength
I bought a Rolling Thunder have I told
you about this you're not rolling
Thunderer's No so it's a spinning handle
too big spinning up think of fat gripz
yeah everyone who's going through
fitness menopause and those were fat
grip is doesn't other thing I think of a
fat rip so it's a handle that that comes
down and clips on to you a lifting pin
that you plate load and then you so that
you've got a you've got plates a pin and
a handle that spins
yeah let's there's wide and yeah pick
that up and get it up to a certain
height now that is one of the most it's
got the weirdest like strength curve so
I can do like sets of five sets of ten
with 50 kilos but I cannot make sixty
kilos leave the floor at all and it's
just grip it's like pinch and my whole
grip
why are you trying to improve your grip
because why not
Banta what is just it's just something
I'm not try it says I guess all that I
won't know we're lucky to do on that and
then lo and behold a lot harder than you
think did you get retargeted with the
discount at some point on a pixel it was
actually it was actually Martin burka so
he's someone who's just all been right
the whole time
and still is rice but he started working
on his grapes yeah I think he couldn't
deadlift or something or he had maybe
had golfer's elbow or something like
something happens he's like I'm gonna
work on my grits and he's gone full deep
and with it like he's and he's competing
in I in mind competitions and things
with it so I in mind are the people who
make the the proper lifting straps like
if anyone's seen a set of blue lifting
straps anyone know what I mean yeah
they're great they're like I've got some
rated-r like that you know that you
would never snap Big Dipper that way
yeah if you all got captain of crush as
well a [ __ ] no use what have used one
Chris no I don't I do not need to do
more forearm work yeah that's true grips
really impressive actually Chris yeah
you should test your grip but if there's
crush
there's pinch and the support three
aspects of grip I really deep on grip on
me yeah by accident there chris has got
turgid turgid and turgid doesn't he foot
well full lean and striated so a captain
of crushes like a one of those
old-school grip trainers it's like looks
like that and you you squeeze it
together and I check in a note that
there's five different difficulties I I
was like I'll go for a three like
that'll be I can barely move it like
it's just so that they're clearly not
just made for like 1 to 5 difficulty for
general population it's like I think
number 5 like two people in the world
I've ever closed it or something but
number 5 is just a solid object isn't it
Rolling Thunder lift is like 120 130
kilos and you hear that and you think
doesn't sound that bad that was
literally what I thought I was like I
wonder whether I order when I could I do
100 kilos not even close not even half
of that look lift
I can even budge off the ground and
you're like Candela lift well you like
what can i improve is he like am i
honestly going to try and hypertrophy my
forearm like you know who's not made for
like if if you are you've been to
world's powerlifting
like and you've got and you deadlift is
your strongest movement you know and you
still can't like a guy that can't get
half it's a world record in that it's
people who are doing like five by five
or 300 isn't it it's it's the it's one
of the jacks when you think he's strong
like you strongest out your mates you go
apart and competition you're not strong
when you win a power of n competition
right I'm pretty strong and you go to
Worlds and you just stand the entrance
and just go well as you see there's a
fella with a checkered shirt who walks
in and cutoff jean shorts and high
military but knows it but that's the
thing that's what you expect but none of
them are like that that's the finish
things on Johnny can you talk to us
about the Chinese lady Finland oh Jesus
yeah okay so warm-up room world so low
it was like Lane Norton Christoph was
Vicky like Ray Williams my all he's like
people you've seen in on Instagram
warming up in this room and in the
corner is a is an old Chinese lady
wearing like bandages like medical
bandages around Ernie's doing tempo
squats with 170 and she must have been
like she must have been sixty odd kilos
but it was just like straight line
straight line just grooving just control
I bar yeah like and like when you've got
like polish world champions like
what's that you know like you're like
who are you and no one really
she wasn't competing in the warm-up room
getting a session if Jesus career but
yeah none of them are none of them are
that they're all just like totally
unassuming like you see them afterwards
sort of in the finished supermarket
buying some like weird cheese and a
sausage or something and like they all
just look like completely normal people
but on a platform monsters would you not
think up doesn't that's the most
interesting thing about people that do
these physical pursuits it's that you
could see them out at the supermarket
you think he's a normal it's just a
normal fellow yeah it's like you know
the people who have done MMA but don't
have cauliflower ear deal yeah you're
the really dangerous bust your lawn keep
away because I can identify someone
who's done BJJ for 10 years because
they've got they've got the ears but
like if you're one of the people who's
managed to protect his ears
you're just a nuclear warhead a
completely thil weapon just walking
around
it's very Fight Club it's very Fight
Club look we've done it Fitness
menopause we'll see if anyone's been
read pilled by that let us know if any
of those points resonate with I know
that they do they either do resonate
with you or you lying to yourself about
the fact that you don't think there
isn't it with you or you don't trained
long enough yeah just yeah what's the
okay so final thing how long does
someone need to do a push-pull leg split
before they're allowed to enter the
fitness menopause three to five years of
pack tech and leg press will do
something like 531 where like you want
to be regularly thinking Monday you want
to be worried about your Friday squat
session Thursday night you want to be
really like you want to get those
day/night you want to be like no no I
can't go out tonight because tomorrow
like I need an early night why it's Rory
it's like six it's the sixth wave of the
threes week five three one
what do you what do you mean why do I
need a little ignite if that's how you
start thinking and you start and you're
going into the gym terrified and if you
miss the rep you're devastated sit in
that phase of time for at least a couple
of years then you ought to do something
else a fitness metaphors club look
gentlemen thank you very much there've
been fitness.com slash podcast will not
such modern wisdom unbelievable getting
wrong every time
sorry protein fitness calm slash modern
wisdom it good luck
well that's for people who want to do
online coaching and we can go to forward
slash calculator if you want some macros
I love it man thank you gentlemen thank
you very much I'll get you one again
soon but for now bye bye bye
[Music]
you